Texas to one that what attention is to
women
I I think men seek intimacy through sex
so I think they don't know how to be
intimate honest like on in different way
yes or no um
sorry do you think sex is to men what
attention is to women yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay so would
you argue that we cheat on men by having
open Instagram accounts while in a
relationship right
I have a question I I said is sex to men
what attention is to women you all said
yes please don't change it now
so could we argue that we cheat by
having open Instagram accounts while in
a relationship
nine posting first track wow
they're the same they're the same right
we please don't go back attention
so so women so women love attention yeah
men love sex and Men love sex right so
if you love attention the the the
dopamine Rush that you get from with all
these likes and all this all this stuff
right
and imagine you've got a man yeah right
however you're posting all these
pictures and you're getting this
dopamine rushing all these guys saying
oh my God you're beautiful oh my God so
you're amazing thank you do you think
that's the same as cheating no uh
emotionally thinks I think everywhere
you go men look anyways not not like
I feel like you get stared at anyways
everywhere that you go when you post on
Instagram so I don't think it's like
cheating I just think it's like I mean
you're choosing to post on Instagram
though yeah but now how was that cheap
though I mean you're posting Instagram
pictures
why don't you just take the picture on
your camera roll and keep it there why
because you feel you when you take a
picture and you and you look at it you
feel wow like this would be good for my
Instagram
so okay so you put it on your Instagram
so what would be the difference because
remember the pictures to make you feel
good yeah so so what would make you feel
good on Instagram
the likes the comments okay the
attention yeah okay okay yeah so so
we're back
and what I'm not doing I'm not trying to
advocate for cheating I don't think it's
okay I just think we have to understand
where the guys are coming from you can
have we we expect monogamy and we judge
them for cheating but yet we're not
virgins yet we have open Instagram
accounts yeah yeah we come in with a
child it's like and then we're gonna say
be faithful to me and they're like what
I think it should just be a discussion
so like if it's if it's a case of you
know what
I want to still do this open Instagram
thing and you're in a relationship and
he openly wants to go and have sex with
other people it's the conv have the
conversation yeah like have that
conversation yeah but the thing is hang
on but the thing is are most women ready
for that conversation hell no and plus
you can't get back your virginity no no
I'm not about getting back here
I might go to church
I'm mostly because the thing is I'm
convinced that meant that a lot of women
like men that cheat right I'm actually
convinced a lot of women like men are
cheap why um yeah because because once
they cheat because okay because you you
you openly choose men that you know are
attractive to other women you open you
you as a matter of fact you negate all
of the regular dudes you're like it's
lame he's regular I don't like him yes
you need negate the regular deeds and
you go for the dudes that you know that
all the other women want to but you feel
special because you're like I got him no
I got him hang on hang on hang on
however you feel but you know that there
there are plenty of women that are going
to be throwing their knickers and
throwing their panties at this guy right
and so you know that there is a
potential for that guy to be in a
situation where he's gonna cheat because
women find him attractive well so so you
don't choose men that are average
looking average earning and average
height you know that you choose men that
are you want to choose men that are
above average in all of those categories
my son's dad was earning the same as me
okay you guys guys would you date would
you would you do a five eight it's like
six three okay okay guys would you date
wait wait would you date a five eight
how much was the average salary here 35
95 35k okay five eight thirty five
thousand dollars slightly over 25 pounds
sorry pounds thirty five thousand pounds
slightly overweight guy all right
I have a question
it depends what average is okay like 35
000 pounds but I don't ask people I
don't ask people what they earn okay but
you can roughly know based on his job
based on his lifestyle you can you can
make assumptions I have I have dated
somebody slightly overweight no he went
to the gym a lot because I worked in the
gym at the time so okay so so he wasn't
he wasn't average above average okay no
she said she already said no no no
no okay I feel like No One's Gonna
believe me but I would because depending
on how he treats me is that your man
right now does your man fit that
aesthetic right now describe your man
right now no but I'm I'm not I would not
I would not shut that down we don't
believe someone approached me I knew you
wouldn't believe me someone approached
me and I felt like you know they've got
a good vibe and they approached me in
the right way and we got along then that
wouldn't automatically be a nah I'm
hearing so much happier that you should
be wearing this
I've had friends that go for guys that
are just like not in that talk about
your friends
but
example that all that friends and you're
like okay this guy is just like you know
she's gone for the below average guy
what not and he cheated yeah and
everyone was like but then he's like
average something about him is above
average women don't cheat like cheat
with average men he might have trauma
Charisma yeah
women find 80 of men so if you ask girls
like you find this guy attractive you
they did this thousands of times they
took data from dating apps women only
celebrate five percent of the time so if
he can see it when you know how hard it
is
it 43 yeah roughly 45 yeah absolutely
and you women know right you women know
you know that there are men who are
broke homeless
slinging dick
and they're broken homeless and they're
slinging dick because there's something
about them because they they fit an
aesthetic right but there are guys who
are stable yeah got gen um they've got
an average wage who ain't getting no
play well as we said one in three men in
the last year have not had sex I have a
question just show of hands um would you
delete all social media if your partner
asked yeah um yes or yes just raise your
hand
movies
[Applause]
so yeah I just I just want to throw this
in as she's like I have such a good feet
Tick Tock but I need my Instagram
yeah I just want to throw them away you
need Instagram and Snapchat in a
relationship Snapchat Snapchat isn't
that where like people send each other
like naked pictures to each other
yeah
I just want to throw this out there for
the representative of the average guy
although I earn a little bit more than
that
I love connection
one thing I do want to say that yes it
is true that the 20 guys which are
pretty much these guys over here uh do
get a lot of attention
I'm just keeping it real but it is not a
lost cause if you're out there anyone
out there who is five eight chubby and
generally over the over the hill no if
you're wrong
I see what he's doing he's playing a
charcoal
your mouth can play a big part
are you talking about what comes out of
it yes it's what you can say you I mean
don't get me wrong you can never talk a
10 into into a bedroom you you will have
to have other assets but there are
people like myself I found myself in my
niche of because there's a course of
studies called the Pandora's Box and
they did an assessment of women's
psychologies and some women like the the
lover and those who go for the provider
and so depending on which Camp you fall
into recognize Where You Are are and
I've always been in the provider Camp
Far More Than The Lover Camp no woman
has looked at me and goes Gotta Have him
but they've been like oh he makes a good
husband he'll probably make a good uh
father right and so I can always swing
that and and you know be successful in
my particular Turf so there is hope and
there is but you got to know you know
they said that for every um fisherman
there's a fishing hole find your fishing
pole and fish in your pond and if you
fish in your pond you will be successful
all the time if you're fishing on
Instagram and you're you know you're a
five foot guy with with 30 000 pound as
an average and you're trying to pick up
the the hot Instagram models that may be
out of your league let's go to the pub
but yeah find your fishing pole and
you'll be very successful I've had
amazingly good looking women for my I
have punched way above I'm talking
punched Mike Tyson level above my weight
and I even was shocked that this woman
is having sex with me
you need to start like a
schoolworks though did she end up with
your wife though um she we were working
towards that I'll be honest
I I actually bottled it because I I
think this there's a there's a there's a
concept in pickup Artistry called
worthiness and I felt I wasn't worthy of
this woman I honestly I was I was I was
in a very different mind space and do
you think she felt that as well she
wanted to get married she wanted us to
move in and I was like you are an
unbelievably good looking for me Banksy
um and you can tell me if you don't want
to answer this if it's not alone
um because she lets you as a provider
you say absolutely uh what are you
paying for everything
um me yeah I mean some things but I mean
let's put it this way if if you're
talking about the split it would be like
80 20 me I would I would book things she
paid for like dinners occasionally
because she was still the modern
although she was Iranian she was still
had enough of a modern British sort of
values to say look I don't want you to
pay for everything I'll pay for this one
yeah but the thing is that's that if she
didn't do that the first few times we
went on a date it would not be any
further because for me it's like I've
got three date strategy if she's not
picking up a check or offering more
importantly offering to pick up the
second or third check
I know that this is going in the
direction that I'm not good man what
isn't that in her masculine energy
though like if that's just what I said
there's just a question it's just it's a
reciprocity sort of process I just want
to feel that this is she's not just
taking me for a ride I'm not just some
yeah
femininity is being kind yeah so it's
like kind if you offer to like buy him
dinner or something I think it's
masculine if you're like I need to pay
for everything no but if you're like
baby let me get it yeah
it's a good way of figures but it's a
good way of figuring out if um
it's a good way of figuring out if
someone's trying to use you yeah quite
often what happens is um you know you
say there's a camp where women put uh
men into the provider cab where they put
them into the lava camp and quite I I
honestly think all women really want a
lover uh but depending on the situation
they're in in their life you know they
might need a provider so I think a lot
of men get used as providers but she
might be cheating with a lover
or even if she's not cheating she's
wishing she was and then she's treating
the provider
not very well yeah you know and and
eventually divorces him as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible